hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report you know people talk about
recession but actually there's a risk
now
that the globe is heading into a
depression
yeah that's right depression the d word
stacy
yeah we're heading into depression and
we might never actually know how we got
there because
we're erasing all of our history and
right now you know princeton university
one of the
great ivy leagues where many of the
heads of the fed come from by the way
and there you find that they have the
woodrow wilson school of foreign policy
and they've now determined that woodrow
wilson was a racist and therefore they
got rid of the name
so i suggested and the fed woodrow
wilson
was a racist after president woodrow
wilson signed the federal reserve act
into law
on the evening of december 23 1913.
he told the men and women grouped around
him quote i feel that i have had a part
in completing a work
which i think will be of lasting benefit
to the business
of the country so cancel the fed right
cancel the fed cancel culture needs to
cancel the fit
everything that's been cancelled up
until now is meaningless unless you
cancel the fed unless you cancel the fed
then canceling all those tv shows
canceling all those celebrities
tearing down all those statues doing all
those protests
is meaningless with a capital m you have
wasted your life away completely you are
a waste you are a waste
if you don't cancel the fed if you don't
cancel the fed then you have wasted your
life it's that simple millennials gen z
baby boomers and gen
x if you do not cancel the fed you have
been born into this world
for no purpose and the fed of course is
what i had said in my tweet and this was
uh this is a motto that has been going
around for quite a few years a
drive driven by mostly ron paul of end
the fed
and so we've had it since 1913 and this
is the systemic nature
of this is that it is sexist
it is racist it is classist by nature in
terms of the fact that
the fed pushes the cantillon effect here
i'm gonna
say pluckies this is plucky's cousin
it's actually woodrow wilson's
you know the the spirit of woodrow
wilson resides in here because he did
create the fed he signed the legislation
and here we are
107 years later and more adults than
ever
live with their parents or grandparents
so we've come
full circle back to sort of medieval
ages when you know extended families
lived in one little tiny room with all
of their
livestock an absolutely shocking new
report via zillow this month estimates
2.7 million adults
moved in with a parent or grandparent in
march and april
as virus pandemic lockdowns crushed the
economy
yeah it's a fractal because uh
deglobalization right so
countries are no longer globalizing they
are nationalizing
starting with trump in 2016 that was the
mandate make america great again
that is a call to deglobalize and you
see that more you know
the fractal level you see that in the
family unit
where people are now living together you
know in america they decry the end of
the nuclear family
right the mom kids grandparents having a
close relationship and this got atomized
during the 50s and 60s and 70s where the
kids went out
and they discovered themselves and they
went abroad and they learned different
cultures
and it was all the television broke down
the nuclear family and values collapsed
and then
the the silent majority was all really
upset because
the values of america well now the
values are coming back the families are
all moving together
they're living in hobbles they're scared
out of their wits
they've clutching their crucifixes and
they're talking to plucky the world's
greatest economist
so uh that's a good thing yeah in fact
what we
found in the zillow analysis they found
that 32 million adults
lived with a parent or grandparent as of
april or about 10
of the entire population lives in their
parents basement the highest on record
this of course could also explain social
media like a lot of
adults living in their parents basement
and they're still living out their
childhood but with the um
the aggressiveness and anger of an adult
and
of course we see the savings rate has
surged in america and partly it's a lot
of the
free money that the fed and the treasury
are creating
and of course if you don't have any rent
or pay bills to pay
because mom is paying your bills and
cooking food for you
this this is part of that
infantilization as well so at the end of
empire
you have a lot of crazy stuff happen you
have giant babies wearing big baby
diapers walking around
you know leading the country and trump
is the epitome of that he's
basically he's like a dude that lives in
his mother's basement
this uh savings rate going up the way it
is really goes completely against
all the economic policies that are
designed to stimulate american
economic growth right because american
economic growth is all based on
aggregate demand and they employ
keynesianism to get to aggregate demand
just go into debt as much as you
possibly can to
to buy to purchase to be a consumer to
get the aggregate demand
going but with the pandemic there is no
pushing on a string there's no way to
create
a supply chain you can't print the
supply chain you can't print
the job recovery the way you can print
money so people are not consuming
because uh the we're entering it into a
depression
and so as such they're savings and
american economy is not built for
savings they have what's called the
paradox of thrift they call the savings
glut
right they vilify savings and saving is
bad but of all those people with savings
now if they converted 50 60 70 100 into
bitcoin
then they could become individually
sovereign and they would save themselves
but part of that savings why that exists
is because
the you know the bottom 90 percent are
spending all the money that they receive
so they're
not saving as much as the top 10 percent
which they're saying is
you know they tend to spend thousands
and thousands of dollars a month
on first-class flights or hotels or
you know gucci bags and things like that
that they're not
able to spend right now because they're
a little bit more uh
scared than the rest of the population
uh
their sheltering in place and exotic you
know in their
their second or third home and stuff
like that but in terms of
ending the fed and ending this situation
of the wealth and income gap that we see
in this week that is our independence
week you know
that the fed is responsible for moral
hazard
and why we are tearing down statues at
the moment
is this this notion of our new morals
that our morals do not abide by all the
the stuff that happened 200 years ago
like we we do not we do not agree with
their morals and therefore we're taking
it down but now we have this thing
called moral hazard
whereby we have all of this risk in the
economy
and this is part of what we believe is
destabilizing the economy yes there's
the racism yes there's the sexism yes
there's all of that sort of
the immoral behavior of our system but
the one of the biggest
moral problems is the moral hazard and
you see that in this next story because
how we're gonna fix this situation
amidst the pandemic
emits a global uprising amidst all this
other stuff
uh and the the lack of faith in
institutions i don't know
pressure builds for a cmbs
bailout in an open letter to chairman of
the federal reserve
jerome powell and secretary of the
treasury steven mnuchin
the group asked the central bank to
devise a long-term
relief plan in the face of an elongated
crisis
though it did not specify a particular
structure for any
such plan this group is a group of
congressional legislators you know and
they wrote saying these
uh commercial mortgage-backed securities
which are
sold into pension funds across america
it under it's the new cdo remember the
collateralized debt obligation of 2008.
now we have these uh cmbs backing clos
the collateralized loan obligations and
these
commercial mortgage-backed securities
you know you think of all these malls
you think of these
of half of manhattan's real estate all
the shops closed
not only due to pandemic but also to
uprisings
so uh they're looking for a bailout
yet another bailout of their moral
hazard system
remember the movie the big short came
out a few years after the 2008 global
financial crisis
and it talked about subprime subprime
mortgages and the subprime collapse and
the subprime
contribution to the global financial
crisis of 2008. so this movie came out
the big short
so a lot of people came up to me and
they said max tell me is that big short
real is that really did that really
happen
did people really know about it and they
profited billions of dollars betting
against the market that was rigged
and i said two things number one not
only is it real
but the whole thing's playing out again
in the commercial mortgage-backed
security market
and within 10 or 12 years it'll happen
all over again
and they said that's impossible there's
laws right
no and yeah it's collapsing again and
it's the big short part two it's the
global financial crisis part two
it's the federal reserve crisis part 12.
and it's the depression part two so
uh you know i wish we could get some
different scripts this script is being
over and over and over again it's like
watching sex in the city the same
episode
20 times in a row gets a bit boring
we've all often talked about this
analogy of the black hole of debt and
the black hole is
sucking everybody in and sometime in
around 2000 i believe we did
pass the event arising and what we've
had since then is this process of
spaghettification
and time has changed as we get closer to
the black hole and and splatterhood
because
we you know interest rates went negative
so time
started to have no value we started to
go backward in time some point uh
about 18 months ago then we had negative
commodity prices with negative oil
prices energy shouldn't be negative but
apparently it is it happened
uh two months ago and now we have a
situation
where we're also seeing the time
compress because they point out that
the letter also listed worrisome cmbs
market metrics
such as the fact that the delinquency
rate hit 7.15 percent in may up from
2.29
in april and is fast approaching the
record of 10.34
delinquent in july 2012 quote what took
years to progress towards delinquency
rates
then now comes in a couple of months the
letter said
right well china will end up being the
dominant economy in the world not
because it will outgrow all of their
economies but because it will
be impacted the least by the global
depression
and america will be impacted severely by
the global depression as well the uk
and france and italy horrible but china
will be impacted
the least by the global depression so
they'll be
by default the world leading economy
it's a fourth turning end of empire rise
of
another empire through disease trap
we're just saying over and over this is
independence week but
uh in a way we will get our independence
once the empire collapse right because
then we will no longer have a fed
that rules the world and therefore
creates all this moral hazard and bails
out all these people who keep on
uh jeopardizing our security and our
safety and our well
amount of well-being with all of these
fraudulent debts the cdo's the close the
cnbs
the mortgage-backed securities all this
stuff that keeps on uh terrorizing the
population
with a boom and bust cycle is i i think
it's destabilizing and i think you see
that
you know it there's no one thing that's
causing the uprisings it's all of this
stuff
right let's change the name of
independence day to dependence day
all right we'll take a break and when we
come back much more coming
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max keiser time now to go
to alex fetzke of amber app welcome
alex and can you just briefly describe
amber app just briefly
really briefly it's a bitcoin
accumulation app so it's about
stacking sets we're the first ones to do
dollar cost averaging
in the world and we're doing some cool
new stuff soon enough which is going to
sort of
take dollar cost averaging and put it on
i don't know
steroids but the good kind of steroids
all right cool
uh people can uh check that out now let
me ask you this
this weekend is independence day in
america a celebration of our
independence from monarchy taxation
without representation and the bank of
england
today we have crony capitalism never
ending bailouts and some hyperinflation
on the way what happens next it's really
interesting i'm listening to a book now
called
but you know you know the great courses
series they do all these university type
courses and one of them is um
why economies rise and fall and there's
this
monkey um you know if i'm going to use
tyler's words like intellectual yet
idiot
uh teaching people economics you know
quote-unquote
um and you know talking about how
you know the what what spawned
the rise of economics and and really you
know it started before
um america really it started with the
rise of the merchants
uh in western europe um you know
netherlands the uk
particularly and it was when farmers
were able to
when agriculture really started to pick
up and um and people were able to uh
do farming and produce food more
efficiently and therefore have time
to do other things now as that
perpetuated those countries became
richer
um people started traveling but then you
know the classic uh
rise state um during that period
alongside the monarch and all that they
started
uh thieving or stealing from people via
taxes and deal you know all of the
things that
we libertarians and bitcoiners etc are
against and um
and we had people you know run off to
the new promised land um and
establish a new place where people could
live
free of these uh these original
financial terrorists or these original
rulers
who tried to you know take the wealth
that people were creating
and you know we they went and created
this place called america
uh which was which was fantastic because
you had
this place built on these libertarian
principles and
the the acceleration of um
economics based on you know free market
quote-unquote wild wild west
saw a place go from nothing no history
to becoming a worldwide economic power
in
100 years and that that goes to show the
power of people coming voluntarily being
able to do something
but then of course you know we had 1913
um and you know
the federalization of the um the states
of america which
you know since then we're seeing the
ramifications of and
and where i'm going with this whole
thing is that um
we we're seeing
you know peak state which probably
started happening
you know 20 30 years ago with um you
know with
communism and all that sort of stuff and
not saying that communism started 20 30
years ago but that's sort of where it
peaked out and collapsed and
we now have a version of you know quote
unquote capitalism which
which is a blatant lie because we as you
said
socialize the losses but privatize the
games that that's such a rigged game
it's not even funny
but where i think it goes next to
finally answer your question in a
really long format is um i think
this thing keeps crumbling um i don't
know
if uh hyperinflation is around the
corner i think these
clowns can um manage to kick the can
down the road for maybe another decade
or two maybe three maybe four
um i think it's too intertwined within
the system but what i love about bitcoin
is in the same way as the founding
fathers and as the um as the people who
first went to settle in america
the same way they did they went to a new
land they went somewhere fresh because
you couldn't change the existing system
from within the system bitcoin enables
us
it it creates instead of trying to
change something within like all of
these
fintechs are doing you know trying to
make payments faster with their banks
and you know
doing wirecard kind of stuff um you know
bitcoin says we're going to create a new
place over here
something completely fresh something
completely new something outside of the
existing system
that is voluntary that is opt-in that is
that allows people to come and
build wealth that is protected that at
its roots
has private property rights built into
it
mathematically not because someone said
so it is like
literally we're repeating what happened
with america um 250 years ago or however
long it was ago
with this but now on a global digital
scale
using math and i think this is this is
now
the the true independence um and
something that
you know will be much more it'll lay the
foundation for
you know the next couple thousand years
as opposed to you know a couple
centuries
the creation of the social contract
which is something that goes back a few
hundred years
and it also was something that arose
during the creation of the nation state
because you did have suddenly a wealthy
class that was
able to aggregate large quantities
of wealth and this
prerequisite a need to come up with a
social contract you know how will the
governed
govern those uh everyone in society
and uh america was the great social
contract in the constitution and the
bill of rights
we the people and all this and
unfortunately 240 years later it's
really
gone back to a monarchy a kleptocracy a
cachistocracy of technocrats and so
we've lost it you know america died
essentially
uh now bitcoin is the new social
contract and the new social contract is
mathematically
algorithmically enforced every 10
minutes
coins are distributed and uh
this social contract that is the vital
essence of bitcoin
is brought into some folks almost
perfect it's almost the perfect idea of
a social contract
and the results are going to be what
some call individual
sovereignty yes so this is a quite a
concept instead of having nation states
and sovereign states
we'll have individual sovereignty what
your thoughts to a greater degree as you
were saying that like i had chills up my
spine because
like it i i think we're living in such a
special period of history like you know
and not to sound pompous or anything but
you you had the founding fathers who you
know
helped you know establish the
constitution and create
arguably you know the the greatest
freest land
in the time right which unfortunately
has devolved into like you sort of
cryptocracy but
um you know we're now at a time where we
get to
to help establish um
this new this new place this this new uh
promised land
uh if i can use that terminology and um
oh man one of the
one one of the founding principles that
i think what makes bitcoin special and
what you're talking about there with
personal sovereignty is
in order for somebody or something or a
group of people to be sovereign
they need to be able to protect
themselves and and specifically protect
private property rights that that's sort
of the foundation
of being able to be sovereign in some
way shape or form like you need to be
able to protect yourself
um from aggressors from from theft and
for the first time in history the um
i mean because fundamentally when
someone comes to steal or
rob you they're looking to take your
wealth of some sort now
the easiest wealth to expropriate is
generally just liquid wealth money
um but you know they can also steal you
know goods and
uh you know that you have around your
house but fundamentally it's stealing
uh liquid money now bitcoin
lowers the cost of defense and increases
the cost of attack
and it does so in a way that
the the the requirement
for a group of people to get together in
order to
enable defense um to deter attack
is actually smaller and it's arguably
down to the individual level
so as a result as an individual um
you know we we have the ability to
protect our
personal wealth which is the thing that
you know generally is the piece that's
aggressed against um with information
with cryptography with mathematics and
it's like yeah
come and beat that like you don't need a
gun to protect that so
but it's also happening at a time you
know where technology is
um converging and like you've got all
these convergent network effects
happening that
allow single individuals to to have more
um i guess say or more control of the
decisions they want to make in life
which then also
diminishes the need for the nation state
to have to exist because again the
nation state came about
um that the social contract the
constitution all those things came about
to protect private property rights um
on that social contract so that people
can you know
live work and pursue happiness that
phrase pursuit of happiness originally
wasn't
was the pursuit of private property or
something to that in fact yeah it's been
changed to the pursuit of happiness so
as you point out bitcoin is
unconfiscatable which is key
uh particularly for groups like black
lives matter who have had
their wealth confiscated by u.s
government just like the american
indigenous population had all their
wealth confiscated by the us government
uh you know unconfiscated ability is a
key feature now the separation of state
and money this is also
the first time in history this has ever
happened speak on this
here we are like um you've got i haven't
read the fourth turning yet but i but i
get the s
i get the the sense that this is what
it's about but
if you if you look back throughout
history you had sort of the ancient
times and emperors
um you know and then sort of moved into
feudal times you know with the collapse
of rome and all of that
and then uh through that we had the rise
of the church which then sort of
cleaned up and these social institutions
these um
these societies that we built you know
the intent was always it's not
you know i i don't believe that there
was some guy in the background flewing
strings like
these are things that happen chaotically
or um
or what's the word they happen in a
complex manner so there's you know
individuals all acting um and
we sort of converge onto some form of
system to collaborate and communicate
and cooperate as
as uh hairless chimps as i like to call
human beings
so um you know we each time the the
system decayed to a point
where you know it was non-functional and
you know there was too much pressure etc
a new thing spawned and you know in the
beginning the church was really
uh a place of of promise that that was
where the promised land existed you know
people
were able to learn ethics you know have
something to believe in that was larger
than themselves and allowed humanity to
sort of
to um arrange itself or or to
to establish itself and move in the same
direction which was quite powerful but
as with all man-made institutions they
decay over time so they have their they
have their lifespan
um and you know the rise of the merchant
the rise of the nation
helped break the um the or really the
rise of science and the merchant helped
separate church and state uh 500 years
ago
but now as we've mentioned this thing
has decayed
to the point where the nation state is
the parasite um in fact it's been the
parasite for quite a while now um you
know
well over a century um if not more and
all it does is
feed on us as the individuals
and it's gotten to the point where um it
is
fundamentally detrimental it's it's in
its
death throes um of its life cycle and
perfect timing satoshi comes around
drops off the most important um
invention
of the last 500 years if not longer
in time for us to build a new foundation
with like we discussed earlier private
property rights at its core
to enable us to then rebuild society
without trying to fix the schmozzle that
is
um the nation state today okay alex uh
great philosophical points
uh thanks so much for being on the
kaiser report 100 man thank you for
having me on
um i can rant about this stuff for hours
so
really appreciate it okay well that's
going to do it for this edition of the
kaiser report with me max keiser and
stacey herbert
like to thank our guest alex vetsky if
you want to get in touch with us on
twitter it's kaiser report until next
time bye y'all